the dramatic spread of covid-19 in China
is pushing the U.S to introduce new
rules for travelers coming from that
country starting one week from today
anyone leaving China for the U.S will
have to test negative for covet before
getting on a plane as Scott McFarland
reports divided Administration is acting
now because it's worried about cases
rising and new variants emerging
hospitals in China are overwhelmed
pushed to the brink and funeral
processions are constant the world's
most populated nation is Awash in covet
in many areas are unprepared if you go
to Beijing they have so many good
hospitals but if you go to third tier
cities or like rural areas it's total
difference but at the same time after
months of protest and unrest the Chinese
government abruptly lifted its strict
zero covid restrictions which had
limited movement and the spread of the
virus China has suddenly loosened up its
restrictions left and right and that's
just provided an extraordinary
opportunity for this virus to just like
a volcano explode so starting next week
the U.S is joining a growing list of
Nations requiring people traveling from
China to have tested negative for covid
within 48 Hours of departure to be
allowed through ready for assessment and
the Centers for Disease Control
announced it's expanding its coveted
surveillance program at U.S airports in
which passengers volunteered to undergo
a nasal swab to better detect a new wave
of cases Health experts hope these new
measures help no barrier is perfect but
putting up this barrier for testing is a
prudent thing to do to try to keep
potential new variants out of this
country for as long as possible
doctors warm weather may be benefits
they could be minimal travel
restrictions put in place at the start
of the pandemic were not able to stop
all the virus or all the variants Nate
Scott thank you we appreciate you